do not try to live forever you will not
succeed
you are going to let the fear of piracy
cover in your life and your work will
visit you will eat but you will not live
home life is no more natural to us than
the cage is natural to a cockatoo
[Music]
those who do not know how to live
must make a merit of dying
life doesn't cease to be fine when
people die anymore then it ceases to be
serious when people laugh
the great advantage of the hotel is that
it's a refuge from home life
life isn't about finding yourself life
is about creating yourself
miracles is a sense of phenomena we
cannot explain
surround us on every hand
life itself is a miracle of miracles
[Music]
life would be tolerable but for its
amusements
i want to be terrible you stop when i
die
the harder i work the more i live i
rejoice in life for its own sake
there are two strategies in life one is
to lose your heart's desire the other is
to gain
there is no sincere love than the love
of food
it is most unwise for people in love to
marry
[Music]
the love of economy is the root of all
virtue
a broken heart is a very pleasant
complaint for a man in london
if he has a comfortable income
love is a gross exaggeration of the
difference between one person and
everybody else
the perfect love affair is one which is
conducted entirely by post
first love is only little foolishness
and a lot of curiosity
the effectlessness of the woman i love
is only echoed by the infernal constancy
of the woman who loves me
marriage is popular because it combines
the maximum of temptation with the
maximum of opportunity
there is no subject on which more
dangerous announcements we stop and
solve than marriage
marriage is good enough for the lower
classes they have facilities for
distortion that are denied to us
marriage is an alliance entered into by
a man who can sleep with a window shut
and a woman who can't sleep with a
window open
every man over 40 is a scandal
and asylum for the same would be empty
in america
the man with the tuesday
thinks everyone happy
who sees a sound
the power stricken man makes the same
mistake about the rich man
better keep yourself clean and bright
you are the windows for which you must
see the world
[Music]
a perpetual holiday is a good working
definition of health
i'm an artist and i thank godford
animals are my friends and i don't eat
my friends
the taste of a man's or woman's breeding
is how they behave in a quarrel
she had lost the art of conversation but
not unfortunately
the power of speech
the power of accurate observation is
commonly called cynicism
by those who have not got it
when a man wants to murder tiger gold's
poor
when a tiger wants to murder him
he causes ferocity
if you cannot get rid of the feminine
skeleton you must as well make it dance
he is a man of great common sense and
good taste
meaning
the environment without originality or
moral courage
democracy is a device that ensures we
shall be governed no better than we
deserve
you use a glass mirror to see your face
you use works of art to see your soul
i have to live for others and not for
myself
that's middle class morality
in a battle all you need to make you
fight is little hot blood and the
knowledge that it's more dangerous to
lose than the wind
the frontier between hell and heaven is
only the difference between two ways of
looking at things
americans adore me and will go on
adoring me until i say something nice
about them
we learn from experience that might
never learn anything from experience
beware of false knowledge it is more
dangerous and ignorance
success does not consist in never making
mistakes
but never making the same one a second
time
the possibilities are numerous once we
decide to act
and not react
no man ever believes that the bible
means what it does
he is always coming with the discuss
what he means
no question is so difficult to ask for
as that to which the answer is obvious
what a man believes may be uncertain
not from his creep but from the
assumptions from which he habitually
acts
use is a wonderful thing
what a crime to waste it from children
i want to be all used up when i die
it's so hard to know what to do when one
wishes earnestly to the right
you will never have a quiet world till
you knock the patriotism out of the
human race
the worst thing toward our fellow
creatures is not to hate them but to be
indifferent to them
that's the answers of inhumanity
censorship ends in logical completeness
when nobody is allowed to read any books
except the books that nobody reads
i dislike feeling at home when i am
abroad
[Music]
while we are ourselves as the living
graves of murdered animals
how can we expect any ideal living
conditions on this earth
capitalism has destroyed our belief in
any effective power
but that of self interest backed by
force
we don't stop playing because we grow
old we grow old because we stop playing
[Music]
people who say it can be done should not
interrupt those who are doing it
a man never tells you anything until you
contradict him
[Music]
men have to do some awfully mean things
to keep up the respectability
[Music]
the secret to success is to offend the
greatest number of people
a little learning is a dangerous thing
but we must take that risk because a
little
is as much our biggest heads can hold
science never solves a problem without
creating 10 more
[Music]
a gentleman is one who puts more into
the world than he takes out
the golden rule is that there are no
golden rules
hell is full of musical amateurs
find enough clever things to say and
you're a prime minister
writes them down in your shakespeare
evolution journalist has never had time
to think twice before he writes
[Music]
liberty means responsibility
that is why most men dreaded
what we want is to see the child in
person of knowledge
and not knowledge his verse of the child
[Music]
if there was nothing wrong in the world
there wouldn't be anything us to do
property is organized robbery
silence is the most perfect expression
of scorn
[Music]
only on paper has humanity yet achieved
glory beauty truth knowledge virtue and
abiding love
old men are dangerous it doesn't matter
to them what is going to happen to the
world the fault of the burglar are the
qualities of the finance year
power does not corrupt men fools however
if they get into position of power
current power
a happy family is but in earlier heaven
no one who is occupied in doing a very
difficult thing
and doing it very well ever loses his
self-respect
there is no satisfaction in hanging a
man who does not object to it
[Music]
an election is a moral horror as bad as
a bottle except for the blood
a mud bust for every soul conserved in
it
self-sacrifice enables us to sacrifice
other people without blush
[Music]
dancing is a perpendicular expression of
a horizontal desire
[Music]
better never than late
most people do not pray they only beg
kings are not born they are made by
artificial hallucination
a fool's brain digests philosophy into
falling science into superstition
and art into padentry hence
university education
democracy is a form of government that
substitutes election by incompetent
mainly for appointment by the current
view
there is only one religion though there
are 100 versions
[Music]
cruelty would be delicious if one could
only find some sort of crude since they
didn't really sure
the fact that a believer is happier than
a skeptic is no more to the point than
the fact that the drunken man
is happier than a sober one
workshop consists not enough staying
from wise
but not desiring it
[Music]
we are made wise not only by
recollection of our past
but by the responsibility for our future
the minority is sometimes right the
maturity is always wrong
i am a christian that obliged me to be a
communist
we are the only real aristocracy in the
world the aristocracy of money
[Music]
there are no secrets better cap than the
secrets everybody guesses
if all the economies were laid end to
end
they'd never reach a conclusion
[Music]
the single biggest problem in
communication is the illusion that it
has taken place
the first condition of progress is the
removal of censorship
[Music]
imagination is the beginning of creation
you imagine what you desire you will
what you have imagined and at last you
create what you will
[Music]
hegel was right when he said that we
learn from history that man can never
learn anything from history
a man of great common sense and good
taste
meaning there by a man without
originality or moral courage
my reputation grows with every trailer
do not waste your time on social
questions
what is the matter with who is poverty
what is the matter with rich is useless
the heretic is always better than
and mortal eyes cannot distinguish the
same from the heretic
[Music]
assassination is the extreme form of
censorship
take care to get what you like or you
will be forced to like what you get
[Music]
when my size money can do anything that
settles it it hasn't got any
socialism is the same as communism only
better english
progress is impossible without change
and those who cannot change the minds
cannot change anything
and index is a great level
beauty is all very well at first but
whoever looks at it when it has been in
the house three days
[Music]
never fret
and only son the idea of trailer will
never occur to him
perhaps the greatest social service that
can be rendered by anybody to the
country
and to mankind is to bring up a family
[Music]
if you must hold yourself up to your
children as an object lesson hold
yourself up as a warning and not as an
example
[Music]
i am afraid we must make the world
honest before we can honestly say to our
children that honesty is the best policy
[Music]
an englishman thinks he is moral when he
is only uncomfortable
in heaven an angle is nobody in
particular
every person who has mastered a
profession is a skeptic concerning
the only way to avoid being miserable is
to have enough leisure to wonder whether
you are happy or not
[Music]
nothing is ever done in this world until
when i prepared to kill one another if
it's not done
[Music]
some look at things that are and ask why
i dream of things that never wear and
ask why not
[Music]
there is nothing more dangerous than the
conscience of the bike
i often quote myself
it adds spice to my conversation
[Music]
if you injure your neighbor better not
do it by half
[Music]